my name is mekonnen Harris from the
Minister of Foreign Affairs of Ethiopia
we've been delighted to have attended
India economic summit 2011 with the
World Economic Forum in Africa taking
place in I deserve an x-ray we have
found the organization the discussions
the agenda put forward extremely useful
and timely in particular with the going
partnership between India and Africa we
hope to use the upcoming Africa summit
as an opportunity to highlight further
the emerging models of innovative
partnership in this spirit of
collaboration we look forward to
welcoming our Indian partners both from
the public and private sector in Addis
Ababa on made the nines 2012 thank you